good afternoon I'm delighted to see all
of you here today my name is Amy
Burkhart and I'm the vice provost for
education here at Carnegie Mellon
University it's my honor to welcome all
of you to this very special event one of
the programs operated out of my office
is the University lecture series and
today we are here to reflect on and
celebrate one of the most impactful
lectures ever given as part of that
program just a little over ten years ago
on this very stage a Carnegie Mellon
faculty member dr. Randy Pausch was
preparing to deliver his lecture some
here in the room today had the privilege
to be in attendance that night little
did anyone know at the time what an
amazing impact those 60 minutes would
have on us individually and collectively
across our campus and around the world
Randy's powerful message that night was
filled with passion and humor honesty
and grace delivered only as Randy could
do his message entitled the last lecture
really achieving your childhood dreams
not only resonated with the folks in the
room but it became a viral video which
has been viewed more than 18 million
times on Carnegie Mellon's yuba YouTube
channel later a book of the same title
written by Randy and CMU alumnus
Jeffries as Lao extended the reach even
further with more than 5 million copies
in print over the last 10 years
Randy's book has been given to each of
our first-year undergraduate students as
they come to the University it is given
as a shared reading and discussion to
orient them to our campus community as
one of the faculty discussion
facilitators over the years I always
look for
to hearing from students as to how that
book gave them an early glimpse into the
values and attributes of Carnegie Mellon
common features they often share include
words like passionate hard-working
approachable interdisciplinary
real-world high expectations and
out-of-the-box thinking in fact several
students have even shared that they
chose to can't come to Carnegie Mellon
in the first place as a result of the
introduction to the university through
the book his messages should give us a
shared lexicon for our work with each
other for example many times I have
shared with one of my pre-med advisees
Randy's quote brick walls are there for
a reason they're not there to keep us
out the brick walls are there to give us
a chance to show how badly we want
something a couple of our CMU alums are
practicing physicians today because when
they were reminded of that message they
did not give up on achieving their
dreams but rather took a sledgehammer to
their real or perceived brick walls and
were able to prove how badly they wanted
to serve others through medicine
there were many lessons all of us have
them we could share for hours and the
lessons that we heard that day are as
meaningful today as they were when they
were originally delivered this year a
team of faculty colleagues and students
have prepared a series of events to
recognize the lasting impact of
Professor Pausch his work and his
contributions to the Carnegie Mellon
community as well as the field of
computer science today this rescreening
of the lecture and the panel discussion
will focus on his lasting message and
far-reaching impact for some this may be
the first time you see the lecture for
others
it will be reliving an event of the past
but I challenge all of us to view this
lecture and to reflect on how that one
person Randy Pausch was able to impact
the lives of so many and I also ask us
to question ourselves in the process how
will we build on Randy's legacy to make
our own positive impact in the world it
is now my pleasure to present dr. Randy
Pausch as the last lecture
all right so what is today's talk about
that it's about my childhood dreams and
how I've achieved them I've been very
fortunate that way how I believe I've
been able to enable the dreams I've been
able to enable the dreams of others and
to some degree lessons learned I'm a
professor there should be some lessons
learned and how you can use the stuff
you hear today to achieve your dreams or
enable the dreams of others and as you
get older you may find that enabling the
dreams of others thing is even more fun
so what were my childhood dreams well
you know I had a really good childhood I
mean no kidding around I was going back
through the family archives and what was
really amazing was I couldn't find any
pictures of me as a kid where I wasn't
smiling
right and that was just a very
gratifying thing there was our dog and
and there I actually have a picture of
me dreaming and I did a lot of that you
know wake up and it was an easy time to
dream I was born in 1960 right when
you're eight or nine years old and you
look at the TV set and men are landing
on the moon anything is possible and
that's something we should not lose
sight of is that the inspiration and the
permission to dream is huge so what were
my childhood dreams you may not agree
with this list but I was there being in
zero gravity playing in the National
Football League authoring an article in
the World Book Encyclopedia I guess you
can tell the Nerds early being Captain
Kirk anybody here have that childhood
dream not at CMU no I wanted to become
one of the guys who won the big stuffed
animals in the amusement park and I
wanted to be an Imagineer with this
right these are not sorted in any
particular order although I think they
do get harder except for maybe the first
one okay so being in zero gravity now
it's important to have specific dreams I
did not dream of being an astronaut
because when I was a little kid I wore
glasses and they told me no astronauts
can't have glasses I was like
I didn't really want the whole astronaut
gig I just wanted the floating so and as
a child prototype zero point zero but
that didn't work so well and it turns
out that NASA has something called the
vomit comet that they used to train the
astronauts and this thing does parabolic
arcs and at the top of each arc you get
about 25 seconds where your ballistic
and you get about a rough equivalent of
weightlessness for about 25 seconds and
there is a program where college
students can submit proposals and if
they win the competition they get to fly
and I thought that was really cool and
we had a team and put a team together
and they want and they got to fly and I
was all excited because I was gonna go
with them and then I fit the first brick
wall because they made it very clear
that under no circumstances where
faculty members allowed to fly with the
teams I know I was heartbroken right I
was like but I work so hard and so I
read the literature very carefully it
turns out that NASA it's part of their
outreach and publicity program and it
turns out that these students were
allowed to bring a local media
journalist from their hometown and Randy
Pausch
where a badger Nellist it's really easy
to get a press pass so so I called up
the guys at NASA and I said I need to
know where to fax some documents and
they said what documents are going to
fax us I said my resignation is the
faculty advisor and my application is
the journalists
and he said that's a little transparent
don't you think
and I said yeah but our project is
virtual reality and we're gonna bring
down a whole bunch of VR headsets and
all the students from all the teams are
going to experience it and all those
other real journalists are gonna get to
film it
Jimbo Lee's going hi you bastard yes and
the guy said here's the fax number so
and indeed we kept our end of the
bargain and that's one of the themes
that you'll hear later on this talk is
have something to bring to the table
right because that will make you more
welcome and if you're curious about what
zero-gravity looks like hopefully the
sound will be working here
this is fantastic it's just amazing it's
nothing like you do pay the piper at the
bottom so childhood dream number one
check alright let's talk about football
my dream was to play in the National
Football League and most of you don't
know that I actually put no no I did not
make it to the National Football League
but I probably got more from that dream
and not accomplishing it then I got from
any of the ones that I did accomplish I
had a coach I signed up when I was 9
years old I was the smallest kid in the
league by far and I had a coach Jim
Graham who was six foot four he had
played linebacker at Penn State he was
just this Hulk of a guy and he was old
school okay humming really old school
like he thought the forward pass was a
trick play and he showed up for practice
the first day and you know this big
hulking guy we were all scared to death
of him and he hadn't brought any
footballs how are we gonna have practice
without any footballs and one of the
other kids said excuse me coach but
there's no football and coach Graham
said right how many men are on a
football field in time so he's at 11 on
a team 22 and coach Graham said all
right and how many people are touching
the football at any given time one of
them and he said right so we're gonna
work on what those other 21 guys are
doing
and that's a really good story because
it's all about fundamentals fundamentals
fundamentals fundamentals you've got to
get the fundamentals down because
otherwise the fancy stuff isn't gonna
work and the others Jim Graham story I
have is there was one practice where he
just rode me all practice just you're
doing this wrong you're doing this wrong
go back and do it again you owe me
you're doing push-ups after practice and
when it was all over one of the other
assistant coaches came over and said
yeah coach Graham rode you pretty hard
didn't he I said yeah he said that's a
good thing he said when you screwing up
and nobody's saying anything to you
anymore
that means they gave up and that's a
lesson that stuck with me my whole life
is that when you see when you see
yourself doing something badly and
nobody's bothering to tell you anymore
that's a very bad place to be your
critics or your ones telling you they
still love you and care after coach
grandma another coach coach set left and
he taught me a lot about the power of
enthusiasm he did this one thing where
only for one play at a time he would put
people in at like the most horrific
Allah wrong position for them like all
the short guys would become receivers
right it was just laughable but we only
went in for one play all right and boy
the other team just never knew what hit
him
because we know when you're only doing
it for one play and you're just not
where you're supposed to be and
freedom's just another word for nothing
left to lose boy are you gonna clean
somebody's clock for that one play great
and to this day I am most comfortable on
a football field I mean it's it's just
one of those things where you know if
I'm working a hard problem people will
see me wandering the halls with one of
these things and that's just because you
know when you do something young enough
and you train for it it just becomes a
part of you and I'm very glad that
football was a part of my life and if I
didn't get the dream of playing in the
NFL that's okay I probably got stuff
more valuable looking at what's going on
in the NFL I'm not sure those guys are
doing so great right now okay and so one
of the expressions I learned Electronic
Arts which I love which retains this is
experience is what you get when you
didn't get what you wanted
and I think that's absolutely lovely
and the other thing about football is we
send our kids out to a play football or
soccer or swimming or whatever it is and
it's the first example of what I'm going
to call a head fake or indirect learning
we actually don't want our
to learn football I mean yeah it's
really nice that I have a wonderful
three-point stance and I know how to do
a chop block and all this kind of stuff
but we send our kids out to learn much
more important things teamwork
sportsmanship perseverance etc etc when
these kinds of head-fake learnings are
absolutely important and you should keep
your eye out for them because they're
everywhere
all right a simple one being an author
in the World Book Encyclopedia when I
was a kid we had the row book
encyclopedia on the shelf for the
freshmen this is paper we used to have
these things called books and after I
had become somewhat of an authority on
virtual reality but not like a really
important one so I was at the level of
people the world book would badger they
called me up and I wrote an article and
this Caitlin Kelleher and there's an
article if you go to your local library
where they still have copies of the
world book look under v4 virtual reality
and there it is and all I have to say is
that having been selected to be an
author in the World Book Encyclopedia I
now believe that Wikipedia is a
perfectly fine source for your
information because I know what the
quality control is for real
encyclopedias they let me in alright
next one
[Laughter]
[Applause]
at a certain point you just realized
there's some things you're not going to
do so maybe you just want to stand close
to the people and I mean my god what
what a role model for young people I
mean just this is everything you want to
be and what I what I learned that
carried me forward in leadership later
is that you know he wasn't the smartest
guy on the ship I mean Spock was pretty
smart and McCoy was the doctor and
Scotty was the engineer and you sort of
go and what skill set did he have to get
on this damn thing and run it and you
know clearly there's this skill set
called leadership and you know whether
or not you like the series there's no
doubt that there was a lot to be learned
about how to lead people by watching
this guy in action so and he just had
the coolest damn toys
okay I mean my god yeah you know I just
thought it was fascinating as a kid that
he had this thing and he could you know
talk to the ship with it you know I just
thought that was just spectacular and of
course now I own one and it's taller so
that's kind of cool so I got to achieve
this dream james t kirk his alter ego
William Shatner wrote a book which I
think was actually a pretty cool book it
was with a chip Walter who is a
pittsburgh-based author who's quite good
and they wrote a book on basically the
science of Star Trek you know what has
come true and they went around two top
places around the country and looked at
various things and they came here to
study our virtual reality Center and so
we built a virtual reality for him it
looks something like that we put it in
put it to Red Alert
he was a very good sport it's not like
you saw that one coming and it's really
cool to meet your boyhood idol but it's
even cooler when he comes to you to see
what cool stuff you're doing in your lab
that was that was just a great moment
all right winning stuffed animals
this may seem mundane to you but when
you're a little kid and you see the big
buff guys walking around in the using
park and they got all these big stuffed
animals right and this is my lovely wife
and I have a lot of pictures of stuffed
animals I watch I've won a lot of these
in
there's my dad he did win that one to
his credit and this was just a big part
of my life in my family's life but you
know I can hear the cynics you know in
this agent of digitally manipulated
things maybe those bears really aren't
in the picture with me or maybe I paid
somebody five bucks to take a picture in
the theme park next to the bear and I
said how in this age of cynicism can I
convince people and I said I know I can
show them the Bears we didn't have quite
enough room in the moving truck down to
Chesapeake and anybody who'd like a
little piece of meat at the end of this
feel free to come up first-come
first-serve
all right my next one being an Imagineer
this was the hard one
believe me getting to zero gravity is
easier than becoming an imaginary when I
was a kid I was eight years old and our
family took a trip cross-country to see
Disneyland and if you've ever seen the
movie national lampoon's vacation it was
a lot like that there was a quest and
these are real vintage photographs and
there I am in front of a castle and
there I am and for those of you who are
into foreshadowing this is the Alice
ride
and and I just thought this was just the
coolest coolest environment I've ever
been in and instead of saying gee I want
to experience this I said I want to make
stuff like this and so i bided my time
and then i graduated with my PhD from
Carnegie Mellon thinking that meant me
infinitely qualified to do anything and
I dashed off my letters of application
to Walt Disney Imagineering and they
sent me some of the damn nicest
go-to-hell letters I've ever gotten I
mean it was just we have carefully
reviewed your application and presently
we do not have any positions available
which require your particular
qualifications now think about the fact
that you're getting this from a place
that's famous for guys who sweep the
street so that was a bit of a setback
but remember the brick walls are there
for a reason
all right the brick walls are not there
to keep us out the brick walls are there
to give us a chance to show how badly we
want something because the brick walls
are there to stop the people who don't
want it badly enough they're there to
stop the other people
all right fast forward in 1991 we did
the system back to the University of
Virginia called virtual reality on $5 a
day just one of those unbelievable
spectacular things I was so scared back
in those days as a junior academic Jim
Foley's here and I just love to tell the
story he knew my undergraduate advisor
Andy Van Dam and I'm at my first
conference and I'm just scared to death
and this this icon in the user-interface
community walks up to me and just out of
nowhere just gives me this huge bear hug
and he says that was from Andy and that
was when I thought okay maybe I can make
it all right
you know maybe maybe I do belong and a
similar story is that this was just this
unbelievable hit because at the time
everybody needed half a million dollars
to do virtual reality and everybody felt
frustrated and we literally hacked
together a system for about five
thousand dollars in parts and made a
working VR system if you were just like
oh my god it's like you know the
hewlett-packard garage thing this is so
awesome and so I'm giving this talk in
the room has just gone wild and during
the QA a guy named Tom Furness who was
by the big names in virtual reality at
the time he goes her to the microphone
and he introduces himself I didn't know
what he looked like but I sure as hell
knew the name and he asked a question
that's like I'm sorry did you say your
Tom Furness he said yes I said then I
would love to answer your question but
first will you have lunch with me
tomorrow and there's a lot in that
little moment all right there's a lot of
humility but also asking a person where
he can't possibly stay no
and so imagine hearing a couple of years
later was working on a virtual reality
project this was top secret they were
denying the existence of a virtual
reality attraction after the time that
the publicity department was running the
TV commercials so Imagineering really
had nailed this one tight and it was the
Aladdin attraction where you would fly a
magic carpet and the head-mounted
display sometimes known as Gator vision
and so I had an in as soon as the the
project had just you know they start
running a TV commercials
and I had been asked to brief the
Secretary of Defense on the state of
virtual reality okay Fred Brooks and I
had been asked to brief the Secretary of
Defense and that gave me an excuse so I
I called them up I called Imagineering
and I said look I'm briefing the
Secretary of Defense I'd like some
materials on what you have because it's
one of the best PR systems in the world
and they kind of pushed back and I said
look there's all this patriotism stuff
in the parks a farce and you're like hmm
okay
but the PR department doesn't does this
so new the PR department doesn't have
any footage for you
so I'm gonna have to connect you
straight through to the team who did the
work jackpot so I find myself on the
phone with a guy named Jon Snoddy who is
one of the most impressive guys I have
ever met and he was the guy running this
team and it's not surprising they had
done impressive things and so he sent me
some stuff we talked briefly he sent me
some stuff and I said hey I'm gonna be
out in the area for a conference shortly
we'd like to get together to have lunch
translation I'm going to lie to you and
say that I have an excuse to be in the
area so I don't look too anxious but I
would go to Neptune to have a lunch with
you and so John said sure and I spent
something like 80 hours talking with all
the VR experts in the world saying if
you had access to this one unbelievable
project what would you ask
and then I compiled all of that and I
had to memorize it which anybody knows
me knows that I have no memory at all
cuz I couldn't go in looking like a
dweeb with your high questions ever
detail right so I went
in and it was like a two-hour lunch and
John must have thought he was talking to
you know some phenomenal person because
all I was doing was doing was channeling
Fred Brooks and Ivan Sutherland and Andy
Van Damme and people like that and Henry
Fuchs so it's pretty easy to be smart
when you're parroting smart people and
at the end of the lunch with John I sort
of as we say in the business made the
ask and I said you know I have a
sabbatical coming up and he said what's
that the beginnings of the culture clash
and so I talked about the possibility of
coming there and working with him and he
said well that's really good except you
know you're in the business of telling
people stuff and we're in the business
of keeping secrets right and then what
made Jon Snoddy Jon Snoddy was he said
but we'll work it out right which I
really loved the other thing that I
learned from Jon Snoddy I had too easily
an hour-long talk just on what have I
learned from Jon Snoddy well the things
he told me was that wait long enough and
people will surprise and impress you he
said when you're pissed off at somebody
and you're angry at them you just
haven't given them enough time just give
them a little more time and they'll
almost always impress you and that
really stuck with me I think he's
absolutely right on that one so to make
a long story short we negotiated a legal
contract it was going to be the first
some people refer to it as the first and
last paper ever published by
Imagineering but the deal was I go I
provide my own funding I go for six
months I work with a project we publish
a paper and then we meet our villain I
can't be all sweetness and light because
I have no credibility somebody's heads
gonna go on a stick turns out that the
person who puts his head on the stick is
a Dean back at the University of
Virginia his name is not important let's
call him Dean wormer and Dean wormer has
a meeting with me where I say I want to
do this sabbatical thing and I've
actually gotten the Imagineering guys to
let an academic in which is insane I
mean if John hadn't gone nuts
this would never been a possible he's a
very secretive organization and Dean
wormer looks at the paperwork and he
says well it says they're gonna own your
intellectual property and I said yeah we
got the agreement to publish the paper
there is no other IP I don't do patent
stuff he says yeah but you might sew
deals often just kind of get him to
change that little clause there and then
come back to me that like excuse me and
then I said to him I want you to
understand how important this is if we
can't work this out I'm gonna take an
unpaid leave of absence and I'm just
gonna go there and I'm gonna do this
thing and he said hey you know I might
not even let you do that I mean you got
the IP in your head already and maybe
they're gonna suck it out of you so
that's not gonna fly either it's very
important to know when you're in a
pissing match and it's very important to
get out of it as quickly as possible so
I said to him well let's back off on
this do we think this is a good idea at
all he said I have no idea this is a
good idea I you know I was like okay
well we've got common ground there and I
said well this is really your call
isn't this the call of the Dean of
sponsored research if it's an IP issue
and he said yeah that's true I said so
if he's happy you're happy
yeah then I'd be fine like Wiley coyote
really and I find myself in gene blocks
office who's the most fantastic man in
the world and I start talking to gene
block and I say let's start at the high
level since I don't wanna have to back
out again so start at the high level do
you think this is a good idea he said
well if you're asking me if it's a good
idea I don't have very much information
all I know is that one of my star
faculty members is in my office and he's
really excited so tell me more here's a
lesson for everybody in administration
they both said the same thing but think
about how they said it I don't know no I
don't have much information but one of
my star faculty members is here and he's
all excited so I want to learn more
they're both ways of saying I don't know
but boy there's a good way in a bad way
so anyway we got it all worked out I
went to Imagineering sweetness and light
and all's well that ends well so I work
on the Aladdin project it was absolutely
spectacular I mean just unbelievable
here's my nephew Christopher this was
the apparatus you would sit on this sort
of motorcycle type thing and you would
steer your magic carpet and you would
put on the head-mounted display they
have no displays very interesting edit
two parts
a very very clever design to get
throughput through the only part that
touched the guests head with this little
cap and everything else clicked onto it
all the expensive hardware so you could
replicate the caps because they were
basically free to manufacture and this
is what I really did as I was a cap
cleaner during this guys I loved
Imagineering
it was just a spectacular place just
spectacular everything that I had
dreamed I loved the model shop people
crawl around on things the size of this
room that are just big physical models
it was just an incredible place to walk
around and be inspired I'm always
reminded when I went there and people
said you think the expectations are too
high and I said you ever see the movie
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory really
walk in the Chocolate Factory where gene
Wilder says to the little boy charlie is
about to give him the chocolate factory
says well Charlie did anybody ever tell
you the story of the little boy who
suddenly got everything he ever wanted
Charlie's asking like saucers he says Oh
what happened to him
gene Wilder says he lived happily ever
after
okay so working on the aladdin vr i
describe it as a once in every five
years opportunity and I stand by that
assessment it forever changed me it
wasn't just that it was good work and I
got to be a part of it but it got me
into the place of working with real
people and real HCI user interface
issues most HCI people live in this
fantasy world of white collar laborers
with PhDs and master's degrees and you
know until you got ice cream spilled on
you you're not doing field work right
and more than anything else from Jon
Snoddy I learned how to put artists and
engineers together and that's been the
real legacy we published a paper just a
nice academic cultural scandal when we
wrote the paper the guys at Imagineering
said well let's do a nice big picture
like we'd like you would in a magazine
and the SIGGRAPH committee which
accepted the paper it was like this big
scandal are they allowed to do that
there was no rules so we published the
paper and amazingly since then there's a
tradition of SIGGRAPH papers having
color figures on the first page I sigh
I've changed the world in a small way
and then at the end of my six months
they came to me and they said you want
to do it for real you can stay and I
said no you know I'm one of the only
times in my life I have surprised my
father he was like you what he said
since you were you know all you wanted
and now they got it in their heart there
was a bottle of maalox on my desk drawer
be careful what you wish for it was a
particularly stressful place
Imagineering in general is actually not
so Maalox laden but the lab I was in oh
John left in the middle and it was a lot
like the Soviet Union was a little dicey
for a while but it worked that okay and
if they had said stay here or never walk
in the building again I would have done
it I would have walked away from tenure
I would have just done it but they made
it easy on me they said you can have
your cake and eat it too and I basically
become a day a week day a week
consultant for Imagineering and I did
that for about 10 years and that's one
of the reasons you should all become
professors because you can have your
cake and eat it too okay I went on
consultant on things like DisneyQuest so
there was the virtual Jungle Cruise and
the best interactive experience I think
ever done and Jesse Schell gets the
credit for this Pirates of the Caribbean
wonderful at Disney quest and so those
are my childhood dreams and you know
that's pretty good I felt good about
that so then the question becomes how
can I enable the childhood dreams of
other and again boy am I glad I became a
professor what better place to enable
childhood dreams I may be working at EE
I don't know they're probably good close
second but and this started in a very
concrete realization that I could do
this because a young man named Tommy
Burnett when I was at the University of
Virginia came to me was interested in
joining my research group
and we talked about it he said oh and I
have a childhood dream it gets pretty
easy to recognize them when they tell
you and I said yes Tommy what is your
childhood dream he said I want to work
on the next Star Wars film now you got
to remember the timing on this where is
Tommy Tommy is here today what year
would this have been your sophomore year
are you are you breaking anything back
there young man okay so in 1993 and I
said to Tommy you know they're probably
not going to make those next movies and
he said no they are
and Tommy worked with me for a number of
years as an undergraduate and as a staff
member and then when I moved to Carnegie
Mellon every single member of my team
came from Virginia to Carnegie Mellon
except for Tommy because he got a better
offer and he did indeed work on all
three of those films and then I said
well that's nice but you know one at a
time is kind of inefficient and people
who know me know that I'm an
inefficiency freak so I said can I do
this in Mass can I get people turned in
such a way that they can be turned on to
their childhood dreams and I created of
course I came to Carnegie Mellon and I
created a course called building virtual
worlds it's a very simple course the
course is very simple there are 50
students drawn from all the different
departments of the University there are
randomly chosen treaty randomly chosen
teams four people per team and they
change every project a project only
lasts two weeks so you do something you
make something you show something then I
shuffle the teams you get three new
playmates and you do it again and it's
every two weeks and so you do five
projects during the semester the first
year we taught this course it is
impossible to describe how much of a
tiger by the tail we had I was just
running the course because I wanted to
see if we could do it we had just
learned how to do texture mapping on 3d
graphics and we could make stuff that
looked half decent but you know we're
running on really weak computers by
current standards but I said I'll give
it a try and at my new university I made
a couple of phone calls and I said I
want to cross-list this course to get
all the other people and within 24 hours
it was cross-listed in five departments
I love this university it's just it's
the most amazing place and I said and
the kids said well what content do we
make I said hell I don't know you make
whatever you want to rolls no shooting
violence and no pornography not because
I'm opposed to those in particular but
you know that's been done with VR anyway
so I I taught the course the first
assignment I gave it to them they came
back in two weeks and they just blew me
away I mean the work was so beyond
literally my imagination because I'd
copied the process for imagine earrings
VR lab
but I had no idea what they could or
couldn't do with it as undergraduates
and how because their and their tools
were weaker and they came back in the
first assignment and they did something
that was so spectacular that I literally
did 10 years as a professor and I had no
idea what to do next so I called up my
mentor I called up Andy Van Dam and I
said Andy I just gave a two-week
assignment and they came back and did
stuff that if I'd given them a whole
semester I would have given him all A's
sensei what do I do and Andy thought for
a minute he said you go back into class
tomorrow and you look him in the eye and
you say guys that was pretty good but I
know you can do better and that was
exactly the right advice because what he
said was you obviously don't know where
the bar should be and you're only gonna
do them a disservice by putting it
anywhere and boy was that good advice
because they just kept going and during
that semester it became this underground
thing I'd walk into a class with 50 with
50 students in it and there were 95
people in the room because it was the
day we were showing work and people's
roommates and friends and parents I
never had parents come to class before
it was flattering and somewhat scary
and so it's snowball then we had this
bizarre thing of we gotta share this if
there's anything I've been raised to do
it's to share and I said we got to show
this again in semester we got have a big
show and we booked this room economy I
have a lot of good memories in this room
and we booked it not because we thought
we could fill it but because it had the
only AV setup that would work because
this was a zoo
all right computers and everything and
then we filled it and we more than
filled it we had people standing in the
aisle I will never forget the Dean at
the time Jim Morris was sitting on the
stage right about there we had to kind
of scoot him out of the way and the
energy in the room was like nothing I'd
ever experienced before and president
Cohen Jerry Cohen was there and he
scents the same thing he later described
it as like an Ohio State football pep
rally
except for academics and
and he came over and he asked exactly
the right question he said before you
start he said I gotta know where are
these people from he said the audience
what departments are they from and we
pulled him in it was all the departments
and I felt very good because I had just
come to campus he had just come to
campus and my new boss had seen in a
very corporal way that this is the
university that puts everybody together
and and that made me feel just
tremendous so we did this campus-wide
exhibition people perform down here
they're in costume and we project just
like this and you can see what's going
on you can see what they're seeing in
the head mouth there's a lot of big
props so there's a guy what water
rafting this is a been an ET and yes I
did tell them if they didn't do the shot
of the kids biking across the moon I
would fail him that is a true story it
was an unusual course with some of the
most brilliant creative students from
all across the campus it just was a joy
to be involved and they took the whole
stage performance aspect of this way too
seriously and it became this campus
phenomenon every year people would line
up for it it was very flattering and it
gave kids a chance so a sense of
excitement of putting on a show for
people who were then excited about it I
think that that's one of the best things
you can give somebody the chance to show
them what it feels like to make other
people get excited and happy I mean
that's a tremendous gift we always try
to involve the audience whether it was
people with glow sticks or batting a
beach ball around or driving this is
really cool this technology actually got
used at the spider-man 3 premiere in LA
so the audience was controlling
something on the screen so that's kind
of nice and I don't have a class picture
from every year but I dredged all the
ones that I do have and all I can say is
that what a privilege and an honor it
was to teach that course for something
like ten years and all good things come
to an end and I stopped teaching that
course about a year ago people always
ask me what was my favorite moment I
don't know if you can have a favorite
moment
but boy there's one I'll never forget
this was a world with I believe a
rollerskating ninja and one of the rules
was that we performed these things live
and they all had to really work in the
moment it stopped working we went to
your backup videotape and this was very
embarrassing so we have this ninja on
stage he's doing this rollerskating
thing and the world it did not crash
gently
and I come out and I believe it was
Steve Audia wasn't it was it
where is he okay ah my man Steve Audia
and talk about quick on your feet right
I say Steve I'm sorry but your world has
crashed and we're going to go to
videotape and he pulls out his ninja
sword
so I think it's very telling my favorite
moment in 10 years of this
high-technology course was a brilliant
ad-lib and then when the videotape is
done and the lights come up he's lying
there lifeless and his teammates dragged
him off it was really a fantastic moment
and the course was all about bonding
people used to say well you know what's
gonna make for a good world I said I
can't tell you beforehand but right
before they present it I can tell you if
the world's good just by the body
language if they're standing close to
each other the world is good and bbw was
a pioneering course and I I won't bore
you with all the details but it wasn't
easy to do and I was given this when I
stepped down from the UTC and I think
it's it's emblematic if you're gonna do
anything that's pioneering you will get
those arrows in the back and you just
have to put up with it I mean everything
that could go wrong did go wrong but at
the end of the day a whole lot of people
had a whole lot of fun when you've had
something for 10 years that you hold so
precious it's the toughest thing in the
world to hand it over and the only
advice I can give you is find somebody
better than you to hand it to and that's
what I did there was this kid at the VR
Studio way back when and you didn't have
to spend very long in Jesse shells orbit
to go
force is strong in this women and one of
my great my two greatest accomplishments
I think for Carnegie Mellon were that I
got Jessica Hodgins and Jesse Schell to
come here and join our faculty and I was
thrilled when I could hand this over to
Jesse and to no one's surprise he has
really taken it up to the next notch and
the course is in more than good hands
it's in better hands but it was just one
course and then we really took it up a
notch and we we created what I would
call the dream fulfillment Factory Don
Marinelli and I got together and with
the university's blessing and
encouragement we made this thing out of
whole cloth that was absolutely insane
should never have been tried all the
same universities didn't go near this
kind of stuff creating a tremendous
opportunistic void so the entertainer
Technology Center was all about artists
and technologists working in small teams
to make things it was a two-year
professional master's degree and Don and
I were too kindred spirits were very
different
anybody who knows us knows that we're
very different people and we'd like to
do things in a new way and the truth of
the matter is that we're both a little
uncomfortable in academia I used to say
that I'm uncomfortable as an academic as
I come from a long line of people who
actually worked for a living and I want
to stress Carnegie Mellon is the only
place in the world that the e.t.c could
have happened by far the only place so
okay this picture was Don's idea okay
and we like to refer to this picture as
Don Marinelli on guitar and Randy Pausch
on keyboards
but we really didn't play up the left
brain right brain and worked out really
well that way
Don is an intense guy we shared an
office for six years right know those of
you know Don no he's an intense guy okay
and you know given my current condition
somebody was asking me there's a
terrible joke but I'm gonna use it
because I know Don will forgive me yeah
somebody said given your current
condition if you thought about whether
you're gonna go to heaven or hell and I
said I don't know but if I'm going to
hell I've moved six years for time
served
I can't sharing an office with Don was
really like sharing an office with a
tornado right it was just so much energy
and you never knew which trailer was
next right but you knew something
exciting was gonna happen and and there
was so much energy and I do believe in
giving credit where credit is due so in
my typically visual way right if Don and
I were to split the success for the etc'
he clearly gets the lion's share of it
he did the lion's share of the work okay
he had the lion's share of the ideas it
was a great teamwork I think it was a
greedy Yang and yang but it was more
like yin and yang and he deserves that
credit and I give it to him because the
UTC is a wonderful place and you know
he's not running it and he's taking it
global we'll talk about that in a second
describing the UTC is really hard and I
finally found a metaphor telling people
about the UTC is it like describing
Cirque de Soleil if they'd never seen it
sooner or later you gonna make the
mistake you're gonna say well it's like
a circus and then you're dragged into
this conversation about oh how many
Tigers how many lions all right how many
trapeze X and that misses the whole
point so when we say we're a master's
degree we're really not like any
master's degree you've ever seen here's
the curriculum
the curriculum ended up looking like
this all I want to do is visually
communicate to you that you do five
projects in building virtual words then
you do three more all of your time is
spent in small teams making stuff none
of that book learning thing Don and I
had no patience for the book learning
thing
it's a master's degree they already
spent four years doing book learning
right by now they should have read all
the books the key to success for the
Carnegie Mellon gave us the reins
completely gave us the reins we had no
Dean's to report to reported directly to
the Provost which is great cuz the
Provost is way too busy to watch you
carefully we were given explicit license
to break the mold he was all
project-based it was intense it was fun
and we took field trips every spring
spring semester in January we take all
50 students in the first year class and
we take them out the shots at Pixar we
take them to Pixar Industrial Light
magic and of course when you got guys
like Tommy they're acting as host right
it's pretty easy to get entree to these
places so we did things very very
differently the kind of project students
would do we did a lot of what we'd call
edutainment we developed a bunch of
things with fire department of New York
and network simulator for training
firefighters using video game ished type
technology to teach people useful things
that's not bad
companies did the strange thing they put
in writing we promise to hire your
students I've got the EA and Activision
ones here I think there are now how many
five like drew knows I bet so there are
five written agreements I don't know of
any other school that has this kind of
written agreement with any company and
so that's a real statement and these are
multiple year things so they're agreeing
to hire people for summer internships
that we have not admitted yet that's a
pretty strong statement about the
quality of the program and Don as I said
is you know he's he's crazy and I mean
in a wonderful complimentary way he's
doing these things for him like oh my
god you know he's he's not here tonight
cuz he's in Singapore because there's
gonna be an et Cie campus in Singapore
there's already one Australia there's
gonna be one in Korea so this is
becoming a global phenomenon so I think
this really speaks volumes on all the
other universities it's really true that
Carnegie Mellon is the only University
you can
this we just have to do it all over the
world now one of the big success about
the UTC is teaching people about focus
oh I hear the nervous laughter from the
students I had forgotten the delayed
shock therapy effect of these bar charts
when you're taking building virtual
worlds every two weeks we get peer
feedback we put that all into a big
spreadsheet and at the end of the
semester you had three teammates per
project five projects that's 15 data
points that's statistically valid and
you get a bar chart telling you on a
ranking of how easy you are to work with
where you stack up against your peers
boy that's hard feedback to ignore some
still managed but but for the most part
people looked at that and went wow I got
a I got to pick it up a notch I better
start thinking about what I'm saying to
people in these meetings and that is the
best best gift an educator can give is
to get somebody to become self
reflective so the e.t.c was wonderful
but even the UTC and even as don scales
it around the globe it's still very
labor intensive you know it's not Tommy
one at a time it's not a research group
ten at a time it's fifty or a hundred at
a time per campus times for campuses but
I wanted something infinitely scalable
right scalable to the point where
millions or tens of millions of people
could chase their dreams with something
and you know I guess that kind of a goal
really does make me the Mad Hatter so
alice is a project that we've worked on
for a long long time it's a novel way to
teach computer programming kids make
movies and games the head-fake again
we're back to the head fakes best way to
teach somebody something is to have them
think they're learning something else
I've done it my whole career and the
head fake here is that they're learning
to program but they just think they're
making movies and video games this thing
has already been downloaded well over a
million times their eighth textbook
Samiran about it ten percent of u.s.
colleges are using it now and it's not
the good stuff yet the good stuff is
coming in the next version I like Moses
get to see the Promised Land but I won't
get to set foot in it and that's okay
because I can see it and the vision is
clear millions of kids having fun while
learning something hard that's pretty
cool I can deal with that as a legacy
the next versions going to come out 2008
it's going to be teaching the Java
language if you want them to know
they're learning Java otherwise they'll
just think that they're writing movie
scripts and we're getting the characters
from the best-selling PC game in history
the sims and this is all already working
in the lab so there's no real
technological risk I don't have time to
thank and mention everybody in the Alice
team but I just want to say that Dennis
cosgrove
is gonna be building this has been
building this he is the designer it's
his baby
to the extent that you can live on in
something I will live on and Alice all
right so now the third part of the talk
lessons learned and we've talked about
my dreams we've talked about helping
other people in neighborhood dreams
somewhere along the way there's got to
be some aspect of what lets you get to
achieve your dreams first one is the
role of parents mentors and students I
was blessed to have been born to two
incredible people this is my mother on
her 70th birthday I am back here I have
just been lapped this is my dad riding a
roller coaster on his 80th birthday and
he points out that you know he's not
only brave he's talented because he did
win that big bear the same day my dad
was so full of life anything with him
was an adventure I don't know what's in
that bag but I know it's cool my dad
dressed up as Santa Claus but he also
did very very significant things to help
lots of people this is a dormitory in
Thailand
my mom and dad underwrote and every year
about 30 students get to go to school
who wouldn't have otherwise I mean my
wife and I have also been involved in
heavily and these are the kind of things
that I think everybody ought to be doing
helping others but the best story about
my dad is unfortunate my dad passed away
a little over a year ago and when we
were going through his things he had
fought in World War two in the
the Bulge and when we were going through
his things we found out he had been
awarded the Bronze Star for valor my mom
didn't know it in 50 years of marriage
it had just never come up my mom mothers
are people who love you even when you
pull their hair and I have two great mom
stories when I was here studying to get
my PhD and I was taking something called
the theory qualifier which I can
definitively say is the second worst
thing in my life after chemotherapy and
I was complaining to my mother about how
hard this test was and how awful it was
and she just leaned over and she patted
me on the arm and she said we know how
you feel honey and remember when your
father was your age he was fighting the
Germans after I got my PhD my mother
took great relish and introducing me as
this is my son he's a doctor but not the
kind who helps people these slides are a
little bit dark but when I was in high
school I decided to paint my bedroom I'd
always wanted a submarine an elevator
and the great thing about this and the
great thing about this is they let me do
it and they didn't get upset about it
and it's still there if you go to my
parents house it's still there and
anybody who is out there who is a parent
if your kids want to paint their bedroom
there's a favor to me let them do it
okay it'll be okay don't worry about
resale value on the house other people
who helped us foot size our parents our
teachers our mentors our friends our
colleagues God what is there to say
about Andy Van Damme when I was a
freshman at Brown he was on leave and
all I heard about was this Andy Van
Damme he was like a mythical creature
like a cent or like a really pissed off
center and everybody was like really sad
that he was gone but kind of more
relaxed
and I found out why because I started
working for Andy I was a teaching
assistant for him as a sophomore and I
was quite an arrogant young man and I
came in to some office hours and of
course it was nine o'clock at night and
Andy was there at office hours which is
your first clue as to what kind of
professor he was and I come bounding in
and you know I'm just I'm gonna save the
world there all these kids waiting for
help to do that and afterwards and II
literally Dutch uncle he's Dutch right
he Dutch uncle me and he put his arm
around my shoulders we went for a little
walk and he said Randy it's such a shame
that people perceive you is so arrogant
because it's going to limit what you're
going to be able to accomplish in life
what a hell of a good way to word you're
being a jerk and he doesn't say your
jerk he says people are perceiving you
this way and he says the downside is
it's gonna limit what you're going to be
able to accomplish when I got to know
Andy better the beatings became more
direct I could tell you Andy stories for
a month but the one I will tell you is
that when it came time to start thinking
about what to do after graduating from
Brown it had never occurred to me in a
million years to go to graduate school
just out of my imagination wasn't the
kind of thing people from my family did
we got to say what do you call him my
jobs so and and Andy said no don't go do
that go get a PhD become a professor
I said why he said because you're such a
good salesman that any company who gets
you is gonna use you as a salesman and
you might as well be selling something
worthwhile like education Thanks
yeah Andy was my first boss so to speak
I was lucky enough to have a lot of
bosses that that red circle was way off
Al's over here he he's probably watching
us on the webcast coming my god he's
targeting I don't want to say much about
the great bosses I've had except that
they were great and I know a lot of
people in the world have had bad bosses
and I haven't had to endure that
experience and I'm very grateful to all
of the people that I ever had to report
to they've just been incredible and it's
not just our bosses we learn from our
students I think the best head-fake of
all time comes from Caitlin Keller she's
a doctor Caitlin killer who just
finished up here and is starting in
Washington University and she looked at
Alice when it was an easier way to learn
to program and she said yeah but why is
that fun I was like because I'm a
compulsive male like to make the
littlest toy soldiers move around by my
command and that's fun and she was the
one who said no we'll just approach it
all as a storytelling activity and she's
done wonderful work showing that
particular with middle school girls if
you presented as a storytelling activity
they're perfectly willing to learn how
to write computer software so all-time
best head-fake award goes to Caitlin
Kelleher's dissertation president Cohen
when I told him I was going to do this
talk he said please tell them about
having fun because that's what I
remember
you for I said I can do that but it's
kind of like a fish talking about the
importance of water I mean I I don't
know how to not have fun right I'm dying
and I'm having fun and I'm gonna keep
having fun every day I have left because
there's no other way to plant right so
my next piece of advice is you just have
to decide if you're a Tigger or you're
an or I think I'm clear where I stand on
the great Tigger II or debate
never lose the childlike wonder it's
just too important it's what drives us
help others denny prophet knows more
about helping other people he's
forgotten more than I'll ever know he's
taught me by example how to run a group
how to care about people
MK Haley I have a theory that people
come from large families are better
people because I just had to learn how
to get along MK Haley comes from a
family with 20 kids yeah unbelievable
and she always says it's kind of fun to
do the impossible when I first got to
Imagineering she was one of the people
who dressed me down and and she said I
understand you've joined the Aladdin
project what can you do I said well I'm
a tenured professor of computer science
and she said well that's a very nice
professor boy but that's not what I
asked I said what can you do
and you know I mentioned sort of my
working-class roots I we keep what is
valuable to us what we cherish and I've
kept my Letterman's jacket all these
years I used to like wearing it in grad
school and one of my friends Jessica
Hodgins would say why do you wear this
Letterman's jacket and I looked around
at all the non-athletic guys around me
who were much smarter than me and I said
because I can and so she thought that
was no real hoot so one year she made
for me this little raggedy Randy doll
he's got a little Letterman's jacket too
that's my all-time favorite it's the
perfect gift for the egomaniac in your
life so I've met so many wonderful
people along the way
loyalty is a two-way street there was a
young man named Dennis cosgrove at the
University of Virginia and when he was a
young man let's just say things happened
and I found myself talking to a Dean and
the Dean no not that Dean and anyway
this Dean really had it in for Dennis
and I could never figure out why because
Dennis was a fine fellow but for some
reason this Dean really had it in for
him and I ended up basically saying no i
vouched for Dennis my guy says you're
not even tenured yet and you're telling
me you're gonna vouch for this sophomore
or junior or whatever what I think was a
junior it's time I said young and I
vouch for him could not believe in it
and the Dean said you know I'm gonna
remember this when your tenure case
comes up I said deal we went back to
talk to Dennis and I said I would really
appreciate you that would be good but
loyalty is a two-way street I mean that
was God knows how many years ago but
that's the same Dennis cosgrove who's
carrying Alice forward he's been with me
all these years you know if we only had
one person to send in a space probe to
meet an alien species I'm picking Dennis
you can't give a talk at Carnegie Mellon
without acknowledging one very special
person and that would be sharing books I
joked with her I said well look if
you're retiring it's just not worth
living anymore
Sharon is so wonderful it's beyond
description and for all of us have been
helped by her it's just indescribable I
love this picture because it puts
together with SIL and SIL is great
because SIL gave the best piece of
advice
pound-for-pound that I have ever heard
and I think all young ladies should hear
this Syl said it took me a long time but
I finally figured it out
when it comes to men that are
romantically interested in you it's
really simple just ignore everything
they say and only pay attention to what
they do it's that simple it's that easy
and I thought back to my bachelor days
and I said damn never give up I didn't
get into Brown University was on the
wait list I called him up and they
eventually decided that he was getting
really annoying to have me call every
day so they let me in at Carnegie Mellon
I didn't get into graduate school
Andy had mentored me said go to graduate
school you've heard of Carnegie Mellon
all my good students go to calling him
on and yeah you know what's coming and
so he said you're gonna go to Carnegie
Mellon no problem what he had kind of
forgotten was that the difficulty of
getting into the top THD program in the
country had freely gone up and he also
didn't know I was going to tank my GREs
because he believed in me which based on
my board scores was a really stupid idea
and so I didn't get into Carnegie Mellon
no one knows that still today I'm
telling the story
I was declined admission to Carnegie
Mellon and I I was a bit of an obnoxious
little kid I went into Andy's office now
I dropped the rejection letter on his
desk and I said I just want you to know
what your letter of recommendation goes
for at Carnegie Mellon and before the
letter had hit his desk his hand was on
the phone he said I will fix this
and I said no no I don't want to do it
that way that's not the way I was raised
you know maybe some other graduate
schools will see fit to admit me and he
said look Carnegie Mellon's where you
gonna be he said I'd say what I'll make
you a deal go visit the other schools
because I did get into all the other
schools he said go visit the other
schools and if you really don't feel
comfortable at any of them then we'll
let you really let me call Nico Nico be
neko harbour mate and I said okay deal I
went to the other schools without naming
them by name Berkeley Cornell they
manage to be so unwelcoming that I found
myself saying to Andy you know I'm gonna
go get a job and he said no you're not
and he picked up the phone and he talked
in Dutch and he hung up the phone and he
said Nico says if you're serious been
his office tomorrow morning at 8 a.m.
and for those of you know Nico this is
really scary so I'm gonna go hot burns
office the next morning at 8 a.m. and
he's talking with me and frankly I don't
think he's that keen on this meeting
yeah I don't think he's a king at all
and he says I'm Randy why are we here
and I said because Andy phoned you and I
said well since you admitted me I have
won a fellowship the officer office of
naval research is a very prestigious
fellowship I've won this fellowship and
that wasn't in my file when I applied
Anika said a fellowship money we have
plenty of money that was back then and
he said we have plenty of money why do
you think having a fellowship makes any
difference to us and he looked at me
there are moments that change your life
in 10 years later if you know in
retrospect it was one of those moments
you're blessed but to know it at the
moment with Nikko staring through your
soul
and I said I didn't mean to imply
anything about the money it's just that
it was an honor there were only 15 given
nationwide and I did think it was an
honor that would be something that would
be meritorious and I apologize if that
was presumptuous any smart and that was
good so how do you get people to help
you you can't get there alone people
have to help you and I do believe in
karma
I believe in paybacks you get people to
help you by telling the truth being
earnest I'll take an earnest person over
a hip person every day because hip is
short-term Ernest is long-term apologize
when you screw up and focus on other
people not on yourself
remember brick walls let us show our
dedication they are there to separate us
from the people who don't really want to
achieve their childhood dreams don't
bail the best of the golds at the bottom
of barrels of crap I'd been there for 48
hours and they loved the e.t.c we were
the best we were the favorites and then
somebody else pulled me aside and said
oh by the way we're about to give eight
million dollars to USC to build a
program just like yours we're hoping you
could help me get it off the ground and
then Steve came along and said they said
what Oh God
and and to quote a famous man I will fix
this and he did Steve has been an
incredible partner and we have a great
relationship personal and professional
and he has certainly been point man on
getting a gaming asset to help teach
millions of kids and you know that's
just incredible but you know it
certainly would have been reasonable for
me to leave 48 hours into that
sabbatical but it wouldn't have been the
right thing to do and when you do the
right thing good stuff has a way of
happening get a feedback loop and listen
to it your feedback loop can be this
dorky spreadsheet thing I did or it can
just be one great man who tells you what
you need to hear the hard part is the
listening to it anybody can get chewed
out right it's the rare person who says
oh my god you are right as opposed to no
wait the real reason is
that when people give you feedback
cherish it and use it show gratitude
when I got tenure I took all of my
research team down to Disneyworld for a
week and one of the other professors at
Virginia said how can you do that and
said these people just busted their ass
and got me the best job in the world for
life how could I not do that right
don't complain just work harder it's a
picture of Jackie Robinson it was in his
contract not to complain even when the
fans spit on him all right be good at
something it makes you valuable work
hard people I got tenure a year earlier
Steve mentioned junior faculty members
used to say to me wow you got tenure
early what's your secret I said it's
pretty simple call me any Friday night
in my office at 10 o'clock and I'll tell
you find the best in everybody one of
the things that Jon Snoddy as I said
told me is that you might have to wait a
long time sometimes years but people
will show you their good side just keep
waiting no matter how long it takes
no one is all evil everybody has a good
side just keep waiting it will come out
and be prepared luck is truly where
preparation meets opportunity
so today's talk was about my childhood
dreams enabling the dreams of others and
some lessons learned but did you figure
out the head-fake it's not about how to
achieve your dreams it's about how to
lead your life if you lead your life the
right way the copper will take care of
itself the dreams will come to you have
you figured out the second head-fake
talks not for you it's for my kids
thank you all goodnight
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm going to invite some panelists up
onto the until our seats up here my name
is Anand a and I'm the human-computer
interaction Institute department head
and while they're getting saddled I just
want to give you a few thoughts on Randy
and his legacy
I joined Carnegie Mellon 13 years ago so
I had a reasonably short overlap with
Randy but he had the presence that you
see in the video that was Randy he had a
huge presence at CMU both with you know
how he connected Arts & Sciences he had
a presence around the world and in
classrooms and how he deployed Alice to
all of these schools and he had a huge
presence in the HCI I you know even
today when we're talking about how do we
are evaluating students how we're making
hires for our department we still think
of the words that Randy used and we use
those words and his in his mechanisms
for thinking about how to do those
things so if we all feel very lucky to
have had him as a colleague you know it
didn't come across in this talk but for
those you knew him you knew he was a
pioneer in virtual reality
and he left a huge legacy in academia
and through this lecture he obviously
left a huge legacy around the world but
I want to tell you about my story about
when I first met Randy I was in my third
year as a PhD student at Georgia Tech I
actually had just flunked basically
flunked out of aerospace engineering and
that was my first attempt to do a PhD
and I discovered virtual reality said
okay I'm gonna give this PhD thing
another shot and I discovered virtual
reality and I had the opportunity to
meet Randy at a conference he had just
given this fantastic talk and so I went
up to him and I said I'm doing virtual
Ivy I can I can talk to this man and he
basically was extremely dismissive and
just shut me out and I thought what an
asshole and Randy could be really tough
you know you see this really nice guy on
stage and but he could be a really tough
you're a really tough guy and it took a
while for me to realize well in order to
be around Randy you need to up your game
I think that's just all those words from
Drew that you know you really had to
bring your A game around Randy but when
you did you got to know the real Randy
you got to know that you he had he
gained this appreciation for you and
that's how I got to know Randy as a
colleague you know any number of years
later I finally did get my PhD
successfully I was lucky enough to join
the faculty at Carnegie Mellon and he
was my colleague for a few years and
that person I saw in the video that was
the person I got to know it's
interesting most of my interactions were
hit with Randy we're at Mellon Park you
know every summer Mellon Park has this
Bach Beethoven and brunch event of every
Sunday and I we would my family and his
family would just happened to run into
each other and we'd spend a lot of time
just our kids playing together and it
was the interactions that I had with
Randy during that time when he gave me a
life advice about everything from life
to had to be a faculty member to just
everything and those are the those are
the really strong memories I have Randy
so I am very very appreciative to have
had Randy in my life even for a short
period of time we're really lucky and
like I said in having a great set of
panelists people that you heard about in
the videos or saw pictures of in the
video people that worked with him worked
for him and so I'm gonna pass off to
jesse schell to start us off it was very
it's interesting to watch the whole
lecture again right here in the room
it's an exciting and interesting
opportunity ya story I wanted to tell
today was about something Randy told me
when when we first met almost so I I
teach at the entertainment Technology
Center now but when Randy and I met it
was at Disney I had been working at
Disney Imagineering for I think all of
six weeks when he started the
and I was given a task which was to keep
him out of trouble
Jon Snoddy who he mentions there had
told me like look we got this professor
coming in he's going to need some
programming assistance and he seems like
he's gonna try and get in trouble so see
if you can keep him from getting into
much trouble and one of the things
that's Randy really wanted to do was to
collect data on the Aladdin's magic
carpet mark one that had been installed
down in Disneyworld and this meant that
we had to it was an already running
attraction that had zero analytics on it
so I was tasked with writing an analytic
system that we could integrate into it
so that we could collect huge amounts of
data which would be necessary for the
paper that he was talking about and I'd
been at this company like you know six
weeks eight weeks something like that
and I was terrified of going in trying
to change this attraction then we might
accidentally crash and break and really
could we collect this terabyte of data
and what's this going to work and and I
was telling him I'm like Randy I I am
not at all sure that this is going to
work I'm not at all sure that I can I
can do this and he just looked at me and
he said well you know you can do more
than you think and he was right we went
down there we did it and it was very
tricky to integrate it while the thing
was running but we got it all working
and and it worked out and we collected
this huge amount of data it made the
collecting made the the paper possible I
don't think that amount of date had ever
been collected on a virtual reality app
up until that point because who else had
a virtual reality app that was having I
don't know ten thousand people a year
going through it I'd stayed in touch
with Randy after he has sabbatical at
Disney we we kept in touch I started
doing talks at SIGGRAPH at his prompting
and he got the e.t.c going and I started
bringing in students from the e.t.c ATS
at Disney and I was incredibly impressed
with the quality of the students and
when I got to think about moving back
east I started talking to him if he had
thoughts about where I could go and he
said well why don't you come and teach
game design at at Carnegie Mellon and I
said I teach I don't know I don't know
if I could do that and he said oh come
on you can do more than you think and
well turns out 15 years later I've been
teaching and I think you know they've
been teaching the building virtual
worlds class in game design class and
that's that that had worked out and the
same thing when I had an opportunity to
write that I was approached about
writing this book the art of game design
and I was nervous and I went to him
again I said our whole book I don't know
if I can write a whole book and he said
do you not get it yet you can do more
than you think and all that time I
thought he was talking about specific
cases until it was it was a while before
it sunk in that oh no this is just
Randy's philosophy of life and I find
the same thing as true now I have
students come in my office all the time
well I'm not sure I can do this I'm not
sure I can do that I'm not sure I could
apply for this job I'm not sure I could
be on this project and then I always I
just think of Randy and I look at them
and I say you know what you can do more
than you think and it turns out they can
Thanks
[Applause]
so I thought I'd give you a little bit
of context about what we were thinking
about at the time the last lecture was
delivered I flew back from vacation to
be there as you saw a lot of his
colleagues from around the country came
in so we knew it was a big deal but I
but we really thought he was talking to
us and we thought he was gonna tell
stories to his friends and to his
colleagues and then we had no clue that
it was for the whole world at that time
and I look back today during to some my
email that I was exchanging with Jay and
Randy at that time and a couple days
after the last lecture Jay and I were
worried because we thought the publicity
would all die down quickly and we were
worried that that might leave a void and
Randy's life and then just about four
weeks later we were still worried about
that and then of course about six weeks
after that the book contract was signed
and it's sort of all history from there
so we were clueless we had no idea about
things going viral but we did know that
that you know this was very important
and we recognized all those wonderful
stories that we'd heard Randy tell so
many times over the years I thought I
would tell one story that maybe put some
of Randy's perspective on efficiency
into perspective so Randy used to often
have oatmeal for breakfast and this
required 2/3 of a cup of water so if you
use a normal set of measuring cups then
you need to do 1/3 of cup of water twice
in order to get 2/3 of a cup of water
so Randy thought this was incredibly
inefficient so he spent a huge amount of
time looking around on the web until he
found a 2/3 of cup of water measuring
device and then he could of course use
that and have this efficiency I never
mind that he had wasted you know
probably a hundred times more time than
he would ever save not having to do that
extra step finding it but it was really
important to him to have those little
bits of efficiency so thank you
[Applause]
in the video you heard about thinking
outside the box so I had just stepped
down as director engineering design
Research Center which was in the
engineering college and I was idling a
little bit not having administrative
things to do and Randy comes into my
office one day and he says how would you
like to be director of HCI well I'm an
electrical engineer by training I have
been doing some work with Chris Casa
back and John's to work from design and
our wearable computers and he went off
founded BodyMedia
I had been working with Jane Segal who
was an HDI person who field evaluation
the systems we were designing and I
thought well it's kind of intriguing
take an engineer and learn about social
science learn about fine arts and so
forth learn what that Andy and said Andy
you're the obvious guy you should do it
and Randy has this way of telling things
like it is and things like you'd like to
think about but you find out that he's
already beyond that and so I asked him
about that and he said well we've had a
search committee and it failed we're on
our second search committee the search
committee says Randy you find somebody
or you're in and I don't want to do it
and so that's when I started thinking
about it but but he also did struck me a
deal you said if you ever need a bad guy
I'll do it just don't make you come to
any of the faculty meetings so the
second thing is just before the last
lecture we dedicated our labs to Randy
Pausch and we have this plaque over here
they're actually in a 2,500 corridor a
new assignment hall you can go down and
see it and it's etched in glass so you
can read it through the looking-glass
and it's a picture of Alice and the
Cheshire Cat and rabbit
saying goodbye to Randy so at the end of
that you need you just hung around with
the students and we can't pull him away
because he had to the last lecture and
on our way to the last lecture he
confessed he had less than half the
slides done he put half of that talk
together in an hour and a half and Randy
Randy Randy could could really do that
and a third thing I want to say is how
much Randy thought about other people
Randy called me up talked to me
personally and said do you mind if I
have somebody else introduce me at the
last lecture well I never thought I was
even in line - you know 12th in line to
introduce him or something I never
thought about it but he was in the midst
of moving down to Virginia putting last
lecture together chemotherapy he thought
enough to call me and ask with my
feelings be hurt if a new friend of his
introduced him that was Randy
[Applause]
my name is Clea and I kind of when Randy
was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer I
was asked to be his liaison or point
person for the Carnegie Mellon
University community and I said sure why
not
so I did that for a couple years and
what I did was I collected things that
people sent him and I gave them to him
and I was just kind of the liaison and
then he gave the last lecture after that
and literally all hell broke loose I was
no longer the liaison for Carnegie
Mellon I was the liaison for the world I
was kind of like the point person so
everybody wanted Randi so one day that
my story is one day I was sitting in my
office and I got a call and this guy
says hi my name is Chris Martin and I
said okay and he says I'm from The Oprah
Show and I'd like Randy and Jay to be on
the show and I'm there okay and he says
can I talk to Randy and I said well no
but you can give me your information and
I'll have him get back to you if he
decides that he wants to do that so
secretly I'm there oh I hope he dies
said I hope he does it cuz that's really
exciting because Oprah was a big thing
at the time she probably maybe now I
don't know so anyhow so I call Randy and
I tell him and you know very calmly I
say oh yes Chris Martin from Oprah wants
you to be on the show you and Jay and he
says well Jay will never do and I said
right she probably won't so I said well
decide what you want to do and let me
know and I'll either get back in touch
with him or you can so he said I'll
think about it
and at first I don't think that he
really wanted to but then I think that
he thought oh this would be a great
platform to
talk about pancreatic cancer and how
terrible was so he eventually called
Chris got together picked a time and a
date so one of the things a Randy always
used to say and he pointed out lots of
times was he never hurts to ask so I was
really jealous very excited and I said
okay I'm gonna ask him so I called Randy
and I said Randy do you think that I
could go with you and he I said I'll
carry your suitcase I'll iron your shirt
and he goes well of course you could go
all you had to do was ask
and I went on Oprah and it wasn't a lot
of fun but it was very exciting and and
we got to meet dr. oz Oprah wasn't so
nice but he was hi there my name is
Laurel Beatty and I'm actually a current
student so I graduated last year with my
undergrad from the School of Music and
then this year I'm in my final year in
the Heinz College doing my master's
degree so I actually read the last
lecture for the first time when I was
coming in to Carnegie Mellon as a first
year student I read it when I was
driving to teach it at summer camp in
Ohio so I listened to it on audiobook
and one of the things that really stuck
with me was the idea that experience is
what you get when you don't get what you
want and I think that mentality allowed
me to start my freshman year and embrace
the mentality of the first penguin yeah
being able to think outside the box and
risking failing and that helped me on a
broad scale but also just on a day to
day to day basis as well so that's a
message that I've really thought was
important to share with everyone so I'm
a Highland ambassador so I work at the
Alumni Association and when I give tours
I always make sure that with the alumni
or the perspective students that I'm
talking to when we go down the pouch
bridge I always tell that story and make
them find the Penguins that are on the
bridge on each of the panels I thought
that was a really cool addition there so
I was a head orientation counselor last
year so I work really closely with six
other students planning the first year
orientation program and the director of
orientation and Michener and as
Birkett mentioned earlier one of the
things that the orientation program does
is they send a copy of the first lecture
to every incoming first-year student so
to this day I think we've sent over
15,000 copies of the book and then
during orientation we have a set aside
time where we particular groups of
students and faculty members and they
just discuss the book and this is really
cool because it's the first time that
students have a chance to actually meet
faculty members and so I've been on the
orientation staff for four years now and
without fail every year that discussion
is the first time that I really see
students start to open up and really
talk to each other and talk about how
they're really feeling and how they
connected with the book they start to
develop connections with each other
because they're really realizing that
everyone kind of reacts similarly
similarly to certain aspects of it and
so it's been really amazing just to see
how that book has been able to bring all
the first-year communities together
year after you so I really hope that's a
tradition that keeps on going for years
to come
[Applause]
so we have a couple of microphones and
not exactly sure where they're but
they're floating around so if what I'd
like to do now thank you
what I'd like to do now is invite people
to grab one of the microphones and
either tell their story Randi or ask our
panelists a question so while those are
going around I'll just kick us off
yesterday I took my son to see Steve
Wozniak talk at the Carnegie Music Hall
and it was a great talk he's an
interesting guy for those who saw the
talk you know what I mean
and when he talked about what a fanboy
he was of Carnegie Mellon one of the in
fact the only faculty member he
mentioned was Randy and I am I question
to the panelists is what is it that made
Randy so memorable and what made the
what do you think made the last lecture
in particular go so viral so quickly
I think the fact that he was dying and
he knew he was dying and he was so
upbeat and so strong and happy that it
was you know it was a it was a I don't
know I it was just an amazing event it
really was I think one thing was always
true about Randy is he was excellent
at taking advantage of a bad situation
right he you know a bad thing would
happen he said all right this is
happening how can we make the most of it
and when so when he got the ultimate bad
situation he just sort of sunk his he
just sort of sunk his teeth into it and
said all right let's let's do this and
and I really think that I I think you're
absolutely right that when do we see
that that combination of you know
someone in a in a doomed situation who
is just gonna like nope no I'm gonna
make the absolute best of this it's not
something that we encounter on a daily
basis and and he did it so brilliantly
there it was one of the first real viral
sensations I think it was just excellent
excellent timing response the world
I mean people from Bolivia called me
what can I do for Randy I don't know it
was just amazing
I got holy water from Lourdes lots of
stuff well I take the thing is that he
said a lot of things that we all think
but don't say you know I looked at you
know and all these boyhood things and
some of them were a notch above where I
would go but there is still pretty much
Mike might hit list too and so I think
we could all relate to him and so like
every man so I'm gonna share something
my name is Dan Whitner and I'm direct
I'm an associate dean in Student Affairs
I'm an alum and for years I was direct
student activities of Carnegie Mellon
and then I've had the privilege of I
started an undergrad orientation and I
didn't do it for a while and I took it
back and I can't remember 2001 or
something
so I shared this yesterday for the first
time in my whole life with dr. Berger
and two days ago so I do orientation a
lot of books do what you call common
read and for I won't get into the
reasons why we we never did that and it
would be so hard to pick the right book
for Carnegie Mellon and so we never did
it so after the last lecture happened in
the fall of 207 and the other part of
this story is Jeff's as low who is a
very very close friend of mine who came
to this lecture and and isn't alum who
wrote the book with Randy and Jeff
actually got it on the internet and then
you know that's part of the reason it
went viral so fast forward after the
lecture and then the book is published
and Jeff and I had kept in touch so I
won't read you what I wrote to Randy you
can imagine it's a long email that dear
Randy we haven't met yet I'm in student
affairs blah blah blah orientation goes
from Sunday to Sunday we're planning an
exciting initiative for August and I
wanted you to be aware this was May 208
we've not integrated a mandatory book
into our program as some universities do
though this year were going to do your
book and we're going to send it to all
the freshmen and I was very optimistic
that this was going to work other folks
in Student Affairs helped come up with
this idea including John Hammond and
then I even said because Jeff's as low
and I were so close that he was going to
be the keynote speaker which he was that
year on August 21st so I tell Randy
about it and then I did not know Randy
well but those of you who know well
this'll make you cry so he writes to me
and on 520 108 and this is of course
incredibly flattering I think having
Jeff speak is a wonderful idea as for
having people involved I think than
anybody who knew me would be qualified
to participate and hopefully they can
share some stories insight both good and
bad that will make it all the more real
and of course if we get really really
really lucky I'm gonna come and do it
myself
best wishes Randy so I just wanted to
guys especially who knew Randy but I
never shared that with anyone
so we are continuing it to do the book
and Laurel said does anyone else have a
question or a memory of Randy that
they'd like to share out Vincent
so I'm Vincent 11 I'm faculty in the
human-computer interaction Institute and
at the time I was research faculty and
still fairly junior not having had too
many interactions with the Randi but I
thought I'd like to share a few of those
one was that in this the same semester
dead that Randy gave his last lecture we
also started a course called the design
of educational games which was actually
I'd been involved in that but it was
also largely sort of a student driven
effort and it was very exciting and and
I figured and of course we were thinking
well maybe Randy wants to come so I sent
an email saying well I know you have a
lot going on and I know you're probably
prioritizing in a major way at the
moment so no hard feelings as if I said
no but I just wanted to offer this as an
opportunity and and indeed it was a no
but but he did take the time to respond
which which I think was extraordinary
and a little bit along the same lines as
as what Dan was was telling us about
Randy's character and another story that
I have about Randy is is actually about
the last lecture so I was one of the
fortunate ones who was here and as
mentioned before we had no idea that
this was going to be such an enormous
worldwide hit but but I remember it was
extremely moving and I actually think
some of the most moving moments were
actually edited out of the video that we
saw today which which was the part
initially where he talked about the
elephant in the room which I thought was
moving and even more so when he invited
his wife on the stage so so it actually
moved me to tears but the funny thing
that happened afterwards was it for some
reason like I think it was like a couple
of hours after the lecture I was in
always of our department and lo and
behold every and he was his luggage
about to leave so I went up to Randy and
said well Randy that was good but
we know you can do better and and so he
lost his big laugh and that was actually
last interaction with him waiting to see
something they want to share one of the
things that made Randy so special to the
campus environment long before the last
lecture was his ability to bring
together you know these two halves of
campus that were are absolutely stellar
from the fine arts to the science I'm
just wondering what you think he would
want us to be doing today that we're not
doing I feel like we've slipped a little
bit in making bringing those two parts
of campus together yes we have the
bridge where you have the figurative
connection but what can we be doing
better to bring those two sections of
campus together we've actually done a
lot of things since then I'll take issue
I guess a little with this so the ID 8
program didn't exist at that point the
e.t.c is continued to grow and strive
and thrive I I think that we've actually
done a lot of things that's also true of
course that everybody else is doing
things too so the competition has gone
way up but but there are things we were
doing that Randy would have imagined and
would have been proud of us for doing I
think like id8 I think we probably
should bring the e.t.c to main campus I
think at this point he'd probably be a
big fan
[Applause]
my name is Lawrence foo I'm a junior
chemical engineering student here at CMU
Randy mentioned about looking at the
feedback but also listening to it how
would he have what type of advice would
you give to us on to how exactly to
improve upon our own shortcomings I
guess I could begin with that because I
you know continuing to teach the
building virtual worlds class which is
so much about giving students unwelcomed
feedback and trying to get them to
listen to it really the the most
important thing is to accept the accept
the fact that you have shortcomings and
be willing to to change them one of the
things faculty members at the ECC talked
about all the time is we have students
who very often I mean some of what we do
is talking about technical things and
craft things but a lot of what we talk
about is what are the different
attitudes of the different students
because often people's the biggest
problem is something in their attitude
just as Randy tells the story about Andy
Van Dam trying to help Randy with you
know an attitude of arrogance when you
can take when you can change those
things it really does change your life
but they can only be changed if you're
willing to accept that it's a problem
and that you're willing to change it and
that's the thing that you always have to
figure out so the number one thing that
you can do is just always and this was a
the phrase I remember Randy had said to
me many times ask yourself the question
what if I'm wrong and be willing to
accept the idea that yeah maybe I'm
wrong and maybe maybe there's ways that
I could do it different than me better
hello I'm Brian Parker I'm a long time
video producer here at the University
and I was the video director behind the
last lecture I thought I'd share two
quick stories that was very interesting
that happened to me is a three days
prior to last lecture Randy called me
down to his
office I was his longtime video director
for his building virtual world show we
had collaborated on seven of them prior
to the last lecture and he pulled me
into his office and said yeah I'm
planning something a little big I really
am looking for a quality video not just
for everybody that's attending that
night but I really want to make a
special video for my children you know
and that hit me I was like how Randy I'm
not gonna let you down but that's right
and I had a small video crew that night
of one videographer myself running the
mixing equipment in the back corner and
the lighting technician to help me with
all the a/v in the room the other
interesting story I'll share with you is
this happened after the fact is it we
had created the Windows Media version of
the last lecture and had it sitting on a
small video streaming server over inside
Hall the morning that Diane Sawyer had
Randy on Good Morning America and turned
a camera at the very end of the
interview in tears saying please take
time out and go watch this video what
happened on campus right after that was
quite exciting
I had the FBI knocking at my office door
going Brian we have such a networked
strain right now from your server on
campus right now that is shutting down
the entire network what can we do so we
went and quickly looked at the stats and
within the ten minutes of Diane Sawyer
making that announcement we had 55,000
people trying to watch our windows media
stream at that time our pipe was very
small and that got out to the commodity
internet but we were able to quickly
pull down that Windows Media File turn
it into a QuickTime movie and put it up
on Google Video
now Google Video is the software tools
that predate YouTube by about six months
but we were able to get the video off of
campus and get it onto the Google cloud
which really made my life a little
happier because I didn't have everybody
knocking on my door
what are we gonna do to fix this so this
is quick story I wanted to share so let
me ask one more question what do you
think Randy would want his lasting
legacy to be right he covered a lot of
things in his talk in fact when I when I
go back and I think of all the quotes
that I sort of remember from that talk
there's many I had forgotten until I
rewatched saw the talk today what do you
think he'd want us to remember the
importance of family and friends
I personally relate to the one about
setting the bar in my class if people
ask me well what do I expect I say I
don't want to expect anything I'm gonna
could tell your creativity I think I
would I would pick that one as well
helping everybody to be as great as they
can possibly be yeah I mean in a lot of
ways I feel like I don't think he I
don't think he intended the last lecture
to be quite the legacy that it is and I
think that for you know for ages and
ages this will be his legacy and and I I
think he must be absolutely thrilled
that that is the case because I in a lot
of ways I feel like the combination of
the lecture and the book together just
they've really do form the perfect
legacy there would be exactly what he
wanted but you know I don't think he had
expected that anything like that could
happen please join me in thanking oh
that's right look this one more hi my
name is Alicia of Khimki I am an alum
and a student I started my journey at
CMU in 2009 as a master student I had
privilege to see his lecture before
coming here and was very inspired just
wanted to share that has kept me going
since then and when I decided I want to
do higher studies after my
the grad CMU was the first choice and
was again the first choice when I came
here for my MBA now I feel that just
want to comment that this tradition
should be extended to masters students
and PhDs as well having reading the book
and sharing the experiences would
enhance the experience of the whole the
legacy that she CMU has the culture that
has his lecture his emotions are so much
there which every one of us shares so
just one wave one more active I remember
a conversation I had with Randy one time
where he was he was meeting with some
Japanese professors who were learning
about his classes and the way he did
things and one of them said I just
things are so different here in America
I don't understand what is it about
American education that makes the
students so much more creative than our
Japanese students this was his opinion
and Randy thought about it and said you
know I don't think that it's anything
that we do in a proactive way I think we
are just less efficient at crushing
their imaginations and so I often think
that in order to kind of get more people
like Randy it's not so much that we need
to encourage people to be more like that
I think we just have to do a less
efficient job of grinding them down the
flipside of that in the sense that I
think CMU has got a very unique culture
as a university and we accept all kinds
of different
metrics for success and we're not making
cookie cutter molds you know if you go
to promotion meetings and things like
that I remember we had a faculty member
from Fine Arts in the School of Computer
Science and we went up to Randy Bryant
and said well how do we get this person
to become a tenured full professor in a
school computer science when they have a
Master of Fine Arts is their degree and
he said to find it to find the metric
find the yardstick show me where that
person is on yardstick and I think being
able to accept all different types of
excellence long as we can keep
encouraging that the new Randy's will
emerge I think it's also very important
that we make sure we build the sand
boxes that are whatever the the next DTC
will be or the next whatever I think we
have to build these spaces in which
people can do these new and different
and out-of-the-box creative things and
then they will do that right if we don't
break them but they will do it but we
have to give them the tools and the
sandbox to do it and I definitely agree
with that I think a big part of it is
just kind of creating these environments
where it's possible to combine
interdisciplinary disciplines but uh-huh
just I think that's a newer idea that I
was really surprised almost really
hearing the talk today hearing him talk
about those courses where he was cross
registering it with other colleges I
think that's something that CMU does
uniquely a lot of universities don't do
and that's where the innovation happens
is it those intersections great thank
you
if there are no more questions I will
would like to thank the panelists and
the audience members who shared their
experiences with us so thank you very
much
[Applause]
and to close us off I'd like to welcome
up drew Davidson who is the department
head for the et Cie hey everyone like an
inset I'm drew Davidson I'm here just
sort of like wrap things up and sort of
point to some of the things we're gonna
do across the year we've heard a lot of
stories about Randy so I'm not gonna
share anything but Randy's one who hired
me so that was a big honor and one of
the things he said that you Laurel made
me thinking Jessica is he when he was
helping me think about leading the e.t.c
who's like it's the it needs to be the
best creative playground in the world
with an electric fence because
creativity needs constraint so you don't
want me to just do whatever they want if
they want to do whatever they want you
know go out there and go start a company
you're coming to a school you're coming
to Carnegie Mellon to be challenged and
so we needed to set up the right
challenges so that people could grow and
foster and I think that's how you can
make the next Randy's is like
appropriately challenging our students
and I see you out there and I see some
alums too so I thought that's stuck with
me is something I think a lot of the
e.t.c faculty think about is how do we
raise the bar every year we're doing
well each is he's gonna be 20 years old
coming this new year and like what the
20 years and so every year like how can
we do better how do we raise the bar on
the students so that you know they're
coming in they're talented they're
amazing how do we give them an
experience that lets them go out and
change the world hopefully use their
powers for good but to sort of celebrate
that like how turning it back out like
how many people have seen the last
lecture before tonight how many people
have read the book look at you all you
read yeah you know for like us I think
over 70% of our applicants to the e.t.c
to this day ten years later we have a
little box in our application form one
how did you find out about the HC why
did you come and they say the last
lecture so Randy's still leading by far
Jesse's the second they've heard about
jesse schell in the art of game design
but you know it's still like Randy's
like that's what we heard about and
we've heard from like undergrad that's
why they've come here so I think it's a
great aspiration for all
is like living up to that so that's so I
gots a responsibility I take very
seriously at the UTC is like how do we
keep doing it better because that's the
only way I think we honor and celebrate
those legacies so if you see up here on
the slide you can go to the website up
here in between CMU and HCI I and the
e.t.c we were sort of looking at events
across the year in conjunction with
Carnegie Mellon's fiftieth anniversary
so this is the 10th anniversary of
Randy's last lecture it's CMU's it's
weirdly I was just talking it's the 50th
anniversary of Fred Rogers show this
coming year that's kind of fortuitous so
we have events planned throughout the
year kind of lining up so in November we
are going to publicly launch Randy
Pausch synthetic interview synthetic
interview for those of you who might not
know is sort of a one-on-one
conversation with the ghost of Randy
Pausch similar to the last lecture he
recorded a lot over 300 questions with
Ralpha tuccio and scott stevens to her
faculty at DTC for his kids and
primarily but he wanted to share it out
so we've been working across time a sort
of like a side project we thought the
10th anniversary and we got 10 years we
can do this right and now it's like
we've got one month we've got to finish
but we're gonna get that out there so
we'll look for that if you go to this
website you see when we launched it and
it's something where you can have a
conversation with Randy Pausch and he'll
answer questions and he really wanted to
do that because it's something he
believed in in terms of sharing it
forward it's also interesting like the
previous mayor of the city named
November 20th Randy Pausch day and he
mentioned Alice we the Alice project is
housed in the et Cie now and run by ET
s'en alum Eric Brown right here and
we're going to launch you know so we're
trying to keep it you know since Randy's
passing and it's you know Randy was a
force of nature himself the Alice team
has been sort of a maintenance mode and
keeping going about millions of people
and kids use it around the world and so
we're trying to think of ways to
reinvigorate that because it was
originally made for VR and VRS come back
who knew a VR na are hot now so we're
looking at ways to keep Alice going and
involve it successfully so Eric's gonna
help launch a competition or a challenge
we were saying competition means
somebody loses a challenge means we're
really wanting to do it with the
Pittsburgh schools
um kids something we're gonna do
November and we're also going to publish
an oral history through et Cie press one
of Carnegie Mellon's publishing imprints
talking to all the people about the
Alice team because it's something I
think celebrating what Randy's done and
the impact he continues to have then you
know we'll have a break we all could do
the holidays nothing ever happens after
Halloween right and it's like
Thanksgiving and then it's 2018 with
Eric and the team the Challenger end up
in March and Jesse's going to give this
talk he's given before on Randy Pausch
we'll let you all know when and where
won't be at GDC but we'll figure out
around Jesse schedule because it's
something like it you know if you could
tell from the lecture Jesse and Randy
have had a great relationship and then
working with Amy and her staff and this
whole event was sort of driven by and
huge thanks to Amy for thinking about
how CMU could celebrate Randy because he
was home based out of HCI I and I think
they're very proud of him and he helped
me out he's one of the founders of the
et Cie we're very proud of him so we
really wanted to honor and celebrate
that so it was part of the Graduate
Student Association we wanted to do
something that week as yet to be
announced because I don't want to
we haven't nailed the guests yet and
last but not least in this summer that's
what we'll end with all the schools and
the kids in the area so something we
just wanted to do to celebrate like Amy
said in an introduction the ongoing
continuing impact he's had both
positively it seemed you but and around
the world so thank you very much for
coming this evening we really enjoyed it
thank you again to the panelists and Amy
and
[Applause]